ASSEMBLY MEMBER KIRK NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. CURRY ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN SENATE BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BURKE CALDERON ZERO
CERVANTES CHAU JUNE CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER. CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA PHONE FRAZIER
FRIEDMANGABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY BLACKY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIN SHOW. MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN QUINN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH. STONE THING
BALADEH THE APPROVED BY VOEPEL
WALDRON WA. WEBER WICKS WOULD
MISTER.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. IMAM
YES HERE CON YOU MONEY FAIR. IN
THE NAME OF THE BOTTOM. THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
OH GOD. WE ASK YOUR BLESSINGS
TO ALWAYS GUIDE US IN OUR BOX
STEPS AND ALL OUR ACTIONS. WITH
THE WISDOM AND COMPASSION AND
TO BLESS US WITH TOLERANCE AND
PATIENCE FOR ALL OF GOD'S
CREATION. WE ASK FOR COURAGE
AND VIGOR TO HELP US FULFILL
THE HOPES AND DUTIES. BUT WE
HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH I MEAN.
THANK YOUR MOM IS HERE WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AND
SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
MEMBERS PLEASE PUT YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART. READY BEGIN. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE BY.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT. ONE MIDDLE RIGHT ARE YOU.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS JOURNAL ASSEMBLY SEEMS
A WINS. SEVEN TWENTY. INVESTOR
FOR A SECOND FOR THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENT AND
PETITION THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE THE
BILL WILL BE TO. REPORTER
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS.
FOR ILLNESS IN THE FAMILY
MOVING TO. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS KIRK SILVA AND
WENT TO SPEAK ON AN INTERNET IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE
MOVE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
EIGHTY SIX AB THREE THREE
CHANNEL FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE ITEM EIGHTY NINE AB
THREE EIGHT ZERO COM LONGER.
AND ONE OH SEVEN AB TEN THIRTY
NINE NGUYEN AN ITEM ONE TWENTY
ACR SIXTY FOUR PHONE THEY'RE
GONNA. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMAIN ITEMS A
ONE AB. NINE ARENA FROM THE
CONCERN CALENDAR IN PLACE ON
THE ENACT FILE WITHOUT A- SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NOW SEVEN EVER
YOU CONSENT TO RE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE EIGHTY THIRTY FORTY FIVE
WEEKS FROM THE CONSENT UNDER TO
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
THE BILL HAS A RUNNY SOLELY
REPORTED TO THE FLOOR WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. AB FOUR ONE EIGHT
MARINERIS FROM THE UTILITIES
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AND
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR
O'DONNELL FROM THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES TO NOTICE THE BILLS.
PENDING RE REFER ALL FROM OTHER
COMMITTEES. TO ALLOW THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
TO NOTICE AB FORTY NINE
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR THEIR HEARING
ON APRIL TWENTY NINTH. PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB FIVE
HUNDRED WARD FOR THEIR HEARING
ON APRIL TWENTY NINTH. PENDING
RE REFER ALL FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL.
PRESUMED TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVEN
SEVEN TWO AM ITEM FORTY EIGHT
AB AT BURKE TO THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS.
MISTER JONES SAWYER FOR PURPOSE
DERIVE. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
SPECIAL COMMITTEE. ON THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
REPORTED ITS RECOMMENDATION TO
THE DESK LAST NIGHT. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO TAKE UP
THE NOMINATION AT THIS TIME
PURSUANT TO ARTICLE FIVE.
SECTION FIVE OF THE
CONSTITUTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE REPORT IS
AT THE DESK MISTER JONES OR YOU
ARE NOT RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MOTION. I MOVE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADVICE AND CONSENT TO
THE APPOINTMENT BY GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM. OF ROB BONTA. TO
THE OFFICE OF ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SECONDED BY MR STERN MR JONES
SAWYER YOU MAY OPEN ON YOUR
MOTION. AFTER MUCH DELIBERATION.
AND DISCUSSION WITH THE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE. AS WE WENT THROUGH
SEVERAL DIFFERENT. DISCUSSIONS
ON. OUR PUBLIC SAFETY CIVIL
RIGHTS IMMIGRATION
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CONSUMERS
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND EVEN
CANNABIS. MR BONTA ALSO FILL
OUT A QUESTIONNAIRE FOR MANY OF
YOU IN HERE ON THE THINGS THAT
ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO THIS BODY
THAT DIDN'T BALLS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AND AFTER MUCH
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC INPUT AND
COMMENT. AND DELIBERATION BY
THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE. BOTH IN
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY I
ASK FOR UNANIMOUS SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT OF
ROB BONTA TO THE OFFICE OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL. THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER MR STERN
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO MY CO CHAIRS
COMMENTS ABOUT MR BONTA. HAVING
BEEN THOROUGHLY VETTED AND
GRILLED BY THE COMMITTEE WHICH
WAS A GOOD REPRESENTATION OF
THIS BODY I CANNOT THINK OF A
BETTER PERSON TO BE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR STERN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG EMOTION.
MEMBERS VOTER TO VOTE. HONG
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
OUR
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO REYES.
CONGRADULATIONS ATTORNEY
GENERAL DESIGNATE BONTA.
MEMBERS. MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS IN TODAY'S WORLD
APPOINTMENTS ARE OFTEN
DISCUSSED IN TERMS OF CHECKING
OFF BOXES. IN NAMING ROB BONTA
TO THE POST OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
THE GOVERNOR AND WE HAVE
CHECKED THE BOX THAT COUNTS
MOST THAT IS THIS HE IS. A WELL
QUALIFIED CANDIDATE THOSE OF US
WHO WORKED ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR NO DOUBT ABOUT ROB. I'D
WAGER THAT EVEN OUR NEW MEMBER
FROM SAN DIEGO WHO'S BEEN HERE
ABOUT- DAY AND A HALF ALREADY
KNOWS THAT ABOUT ROB BONTA. YES
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT EXPERIENCE
IN THE COURT ROOM AND LOCAL
GOVRNMENT. HE WILL BRING ALL
OF THOSE ASSETS TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. GIVEN THE
RECENT INCREASED AWARENESS OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS OF
PEOPLE IN THE API COMMUNITIES
IT IS ALSO REASSURING TO HAVE A
MEMBER OF SE
THE STATE'S TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT
SPOT. FINALLY ROB CHECKS
ANOTHER BOX THAT IS IMPORTANT
TO ME. I THINK IT IS IN
CRITICAL I THINK IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE CALIFORNIA HAVE A
PROGRESSIVE VOICE AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL. EVEN MORE SO AS THIS
NATION MOVED TO RE EVALUATE OUR
APPROACH TO PUBLIC SAFETY. I AM
SORRY TO LOSE YET ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE IS
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS. HOWEVER FOR
ALL OF THESE REASONS MENTIONED.
I AM VERY VERY PLEASED THAT WE
HAVE VOTED TO SUPPORT ROB BONTA
TODAY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER. MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU EVERYBODY I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE TRUST YOU PLACED
IN ME BY CONFIRMING HIS
NOMINATION FOR ME TO SERVICE
CALIFORNIA'S NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL I'M- EXTREMELY HUMBLED
VERY HONORED AND- I'M CLEAR
EYED ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT
LIE AHEAD FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND I THINK I HAVE A-
IT A SECRET WEAPON AND A
DISTINCT ADVANTAGE IN THAT IS
THAT MY GOOD FORTUNE HAS BEEN
THAT MY PATH HAS COME THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATURE. I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SERVE WITH ALL OF YOU
I'VE LEARNED FROM YOUR PASSIONS
YOUR PRIORITIES. I BROWN BY
SERVING WITH YOU OVER THE LAST
EIGHT PLUS YEARS. I'VE SEEN HOW
HARD WE FIGHT FOR. COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HURTING AND ISSUES
THAT ARE PASSING. AND IT'S MADE
ME WANT TO FIGHT TO FIGHT FOR A
BETTER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN SEEN. AND
WHO NEED A CHAMPION. AND I HOPE
THAT THAT THE SHIP THAT WE
FORGE WILL CONTINUE I INVITED I
ASKED FOR IT I THINK THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WILL BETTER BE
BETTER OFF IF WE'RE ALL WORKING
TOGETHER AND I THINK THE
FRIENDSHIPS AND THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE'VE HAD
HERE- HAVE BEEN DEEPLY
MEANINGFUL TO ME DEFINITELY
PERSONALLY BENEFICIAL TO ME AS
I BROWN ANOTHER AS I'VE LEARNED
AND WE'VE WE'VE DONE WHAT THIS
BODY. IS SUPPOSED TO DO WE'VE
COME. FROM ALL OVER THE STATE.
WE'VE COME FROM NORTH AND SOUTH
AND CENTRAL FROM URBAN AND
RURAL AND SUBURBAN FROM COASTAL
AND INLAND BRINGING WITH US.
OUR. CONSTITUENTS ARE
COMMUNITIES PLACING THE PROBLEM
SQUARELY ON THE TABLE AND
DELIBERATING TO IDENTIFY
SOLUTIONS. AND I HOPE THAT
WON'T STOP. AS I HAVE THE HONOR
PRIVILEGE OF MOVING INTO THIS
NEW ROLE AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FOR WHOM I HAVE NOT HAD THE
PLEASURE OF BEING IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND SPENDING TIME
LEARNING ABOUT YOUR COMMUNITY
AND ISSUES. I WOULD BE HONORED
TO DO SO IF YOU HAVE ME I THINK
WE'LL MAKE A BETTER CALIFORNIA-
IF WE DO THAT. AND I'LL SAY
THAT TODAY IS. A BITTER SWEET
DAY FOR ME. PEOPLE HAVE ASKED
ME WHAT IS. WHAT DO YOU HOW DO
YOU FEEL ABOUT BEING AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND FOR THE
LAST EIGHT PLUS YEARS I'VE SAID
IT'S THE BEST JOB I'VE EVER HAD.
AND IT'S BEEN THAT AND MORE
EVERY TIME. I WALKED ON THE
SCREEN CARPET FROM THE FIRST
DAY. UNTIL THIS DAY. I
APPRECIATED THAT THE PRIVILEGE.
AND THE HONOR OF SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
KNOW YOU DO TOO AND I'M PROUD
OF WHAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED.
USHERED IN NEEDED REFORM. WE'VE
SWUNG FOR THE FENCE AND HELPED.
REEMPHASIZED REAFFIRM THAT
PHRASE AND POLITICS THAT AS
CALIFORNIA GOES SO GOES THE
NATION WE'VE BEEN FIRST WE'VE
BEEN BALLS- WE FOUGHT FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND MADE A
DIFFERENCE ON ISSUES THAT.
AFFECT CALIFORNIA THAT AFFECT
THE NATION THAT I OFTENTIMES.
AFFECT THE WORLD SO I AM PROUD.
OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
HERE AND THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE TOGETHER. I ALSO WANT TO
SAY A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO. THE
INCOMING CLASS OF TWENTY TWELVE.
A HISTORICALLY LARGE CLASS M.
AND HISTORICALLY LONG SERVING
CLASS. AFTER WE FOUND THE
BATHROOMS TOGETHER WE GOT TO
WORK RIGHT AWAY AND WE'VE DONE
SOME AMAZING THINGS- THE VOTES
ON THE FLOOR THE MOMENTS WE
SHARED THE FIGHTS WE FOUGHT THE
CHANGE WE MADE- IS A PRIVILEGE
ON NEVER FORGET. AND WE HAVE
LEFT A MARK AND WE'RE STILL
MAKING THAT MARK WE ARE WE HAVE
LEFT A LEGACY AND WE'RE STILL
CREATING THAT LEGACY SITE I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH IS AN
HONOR IT IS TO HAVE BEEN PART
OF THAT AND TO BE PART OF THAT
CLASS OF TWENTY TWELVE- I WANT
TO SHARE SOME THANK YOUS- FIRST
TO MY WIFE MIA. WHO IS HERE- UP
IN THE GALLERY. MY PARTNER IN
LIFE. HE'S MY PARTNER IN LIFE
MY PARTNER AND SERVICE WE MET
WHEN WE WERE ALL OF SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD SO YOU KNOW SHE HAS A
HIGH THRESHOLD FOR PAIN HAVE
BEEN WITH ME ALL THIS YEAR'S.
AND EVERYTHING THAT I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO. BE A PART OF IN THIS
INCREDIBLE SOUNDLY ALL OF THAT
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE THE
COMPLIMENTS THAT WE HAD. I
COULD HAVE DONE WITHOUT HER SO
THANK MEDIA. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK MY CHILDREN I HAVE THREE
AMAZING CHILDREN. REINA ELIANA
AND ANDREAS THEY'VE GIVEN ME
THE JOY OF A LIFETIME TO BE
THEIR DAD. AND REINA IS HERE MY
OLDEST WHO IF YOU CAN BELIEVE
IT TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD ON
SATURDAY. AND SHE'S HERE WITH
US AS WELL. MY PARENTS CAN MAKE
IT TODAY BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MY PARENTS AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW WHO HEARD MY STORY
THEY'RE MY BIGGEST SUPPORTERS
AND MY BIGGEST INSPIRATION. AND
I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
INCREDIBLE STAFF MY CAPITOL
STAFF. MY DISTRICT STAFF. I
BELIEVE. IN MY OPINION THE BEST
STAFF IN THE BUSINESS. WE LOVE
OUR STATE DEARLY AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS EVEN MORE. AND I
LOVE THEM FOR PROVIDING FOR
THEM. AND I WANT TO SAY SHUT UP
TO BE ON A SET UP MY CHIEF OF
STAFF. NO AND YOU CAN'T FIND A
BETTER TV STAFF. NO ONE WORKS
HARDER NO WORKS- AND NO ONE
WORKS THAN THAN VIVIANA AND I'M
THAT SO BE COMING UP TO THE
JUSTICE TO BE MY CHIEF OF STAFF
THERE AS WELL. I'M ALSO A TO
SAY SHUT UP TO ADDRESS OF MY
TEAM. MEDINA MAD. LEANDER MAKE
YOUR OWN CAR MORE SO CORTES. I
A GLASS. WHEN GOMEZ DURING
COVER HOW AND- ANALYSTS A
SUDDEN. AND ALSO SAY THANK YOU
TO ALL MY FORMER STAFF OVER THE
YEAR. FOR THEIR SERVICE FOR THE
JOY. OF WITH THEM. IN THE MIDST
BEST UP THE PEOPLE DISTURBING-
ALAMEDA FAMILY UNDER YOU'VE
HEARD ME. THEM FIGHT FOR THEM
MANY TIMES ON THIS FLOOR- I.
THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR OF ABLE
TO SERVE YOU I FOR THIS YOU. IN
IN MY TO PASS. ALSO JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU TO THE ENTIRE
ASSEMBLY. A STAFF TEAM FAMILY
THAT MAKES THE THIS HOUSE AND
GO THAT ALLOWS US TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE. I
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU. AND HOW
TO BE A PART OF THIS TEAM. LET
ME JUST END BY BY SAYING THIS
AGAIN. I KNOW THAT. THE
CHALLENGES ARE ARE MANY- MY
VIEW OF THE ROLE OF THE STATE
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS.
THAT THE TWENTY JOURNAL SHOULD
BE THE PEOPLE'S ATTORNEY. TO
FIGHT FOR. EVERYDAY FOLKS THE
VULNERABLE. THE VOICELESSTHE
DISADVANTAGE THOSE WHO NEED TO
CHAMPION THOSE WERE HURTING
BEING ABUSED. AND TO PUSH BACK
AND FIGHT BACK AGAINST. THOSE
IN POWER WHO ARE OVER WE CANNOT
POWER ABUSING THAT POWER THAT
JOB. AND I'M GONNA DO MY BEST
I'M GONNA TRY TO HELP AS MANY
PEOPLE AS I CAN TO DO AS MUCH
GOOD AS POSSIBLE. AND I HELP IN
THAT PROCESS- MAKE MY FAMILY
ALL OF YOU IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROP. THANK YOU.
MR
BONTA WHILE YOU WERE TALKING
THE SENATE VOTED TO CONFIRM
YOUR CONFIRMATION. SO. I GUESS
WE THE FIRST. I AM PROUD TO BE
THE FIRST PERSON TO CALL YOUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL DESIGNATE ROB
BONTA CAN GRADUATION. YOU KNOW
I SPEAK FOR ALL OF US WHEN I
SAY IT WAS AN HONOR TO SERVE
WITH YOU ON THIS GREEN CARPET
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP. MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FORTY
SEVEN. ARE ON THE SECOND
READING FILE THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTY
TROUBLES SEVEN WITHIN MINUTES
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO WITH A
MEMBERS THREE THREE WITH A
MEMBERSFOR NINETY FOUR WITH A
MINUTES THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH A MEMBER ONE TWENTY SO
TWELVE. NINETY WITH A MEMBERS
NINETY WITH MINUTES TOTAL THREE
WITH A MAN TOLD EIGHT WITH A
MEMBER 624-229-6290 EIGHT REAL
SIX THREE SEVENTEEN.
384-401-4405 OR 661-956-4046
SEVEN THREE SEVEN FORTY TWO.
NINE FIFTY SEVEN TOTAL
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT TEN SIXTY
FIVE ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWELVE NINETY TWELVE
NINETY ONE THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN FIFTEEN
EIGHTY TWO FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE OR SIXTY
FIVE. FIVE THIRTY FIVE IT'LL
FOUR BY FORTY SIX A
571-402-1103 WITH THE MEMBERS
AND ASSEMBLY BILL. FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOUR WITH A MENACE. A
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
DEEMED. FILE ITEM. EIGHT HAS
BEEN. WITH. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE I FOR NINE AND.
FIFTY MEMBERS WILL BE TAKING UP
I FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY ONE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT WITH THE
MINUTES BY SOME MEMBER OF OUR
QUE HAN. SOME OF OUR CAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
MOMENTS. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
AMEND AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
AMENDMENTS SIMPLY ELIMINATE
GENDER REFERENCES IN COACH
DIRECTORS AND THE GOVERNOR
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESOURCES ALONG WITH ADDING A
CO AUTHOR. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON ADOPTING THESE
AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THE BEST A NAY AYE
AYES HAVE IT. EMITTER DARTED
OUT TO PRINT BACK ON FILE. WE
PASSING ON OF ITEMS. FIFTY TO
FIFTY SIX. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN COURT AGREED.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE HUNDRED BY
SIMPLY REVERTING AND OTHERS AN
ACT RELATING TO PRODUCT SAFETY.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWELVE
HUNDRED IS A SAFER FOOD
PACKAGING AND COOKWARE. THE
IT'S FOR WORKING TO LIMIT THE
EXPOSURE OF DANGEROUS CHEMICALS
IN OUR FOOD PACKAGING AS WELL
AS OUR COOKWARE THE PARTICULAR
ONE CHEMICAL. WE HAVE P. FAST
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE WATCHING IN LIMITING DOT
FROM FOOD PACKAGING AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE THAT OUR COOKWARE
HAS A PROPER LABELING SORTS
CONSUMERS. WE CAN MAKE THE
DECISION WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT
TO BUY COOKWARE. WHETHER OR NOT
WE WANT BY COOKWARE ALL WITH
THESE TYPES OF CHEMICALS.
COMPANIES LIKE MCDONALD'S TACO
BELL AND CHIPOTLE HAVE ALREADY
COMMITTED TO PHASING OUT P.
FAST IN THEIR FOOD PACKAGING.
AS WELL AS NEW YORK HAS ALREADY
TAKEN THE STAND LAST YEAR TO
BAN P. FAST OUT OF THE FOOD
PACKAGING. IN ADDITION WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT COOKWARE LIKE
NONSTICK PANS AS WELL AS
DIFFERENT BIG WHERE IS PROPERLY
LABELED. WITH WARNING LABELS
WITH DANGEROUS CHEMICALS TO THE
WE HAVE CONSUMERS CAN MAKE
THOSE EDUCATED CHOICES WITHOUT
A RESPECT FOR YES FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB. TWELVE HUNDRED. THANK
YOU MR TANG SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. OUR MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL. CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES IS THREE
KNOWS THE MEASURE. WE WILL PASS
RETAIN ON FIVE ITEMS EIGHT.
THROUGH SIXTY FIVE. EVEN IF I
LEADING SIXTIES AB THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE BIASA MEMBER FOR AND
RELATING TO. MR FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. BUT THE MAN'S. I
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB THREE
THIS BILL AIMS TO CURB ILLEGAL
STREET RACING BY STOPPING AT AT
A CRITICAL SOURCE THE MOTOR
VEHICLE EXHIBITION OF SPEED THE
MOTOR VEHICLE EXHIBITION OF
SPEED OR THE ACTIVITIES AND
STANDS PERFORMED IN A VEHICLE
AT DANGEROUS SPEEDS TO SHOW OFF
TO A CROWD. THESE ARE THE SIDE
SHOWS HAPPENING OUR STREETS
BEFORE LEGAL SHE RACES. AS THE
COVERT NINETEEN SHUT DOWNS
CLEARED THE STREETS. MOVIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAVE SEEN A
STAGGERING SPIKE IN THIS
RECKLESS ACTIVITY LAST YEAR
ALONE. THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL RESPONDED TO OVER TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CALLS INVOLVING
EXHIBITION OF SPEED AND STREET
RACING AND REPORTED A NEARLY
3100% SURGE IN MOTOR VEHICLE
EXHIBITION S. B. CITATION. BUT
SADLY. NOT ALL SPEED EXHIBITION
CASES AND WITH. MANY LEAD TO
DEVASTATING CRASHES AND
SENSELESS DEATHS OF OUR YOUTH.
THIS RECKLESS BEHAVIOR HANS OUR
STREETS CLAIMS INNOCENT LIVES
INPUTS COMMUTERS PEDESTRIANS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AT FATAL
RISK. I'M SURE WE ALL KNOW
THESE TRAGIC CRASHES. IN OUR
OWN COMMUNITIES IN OUR OWN
NEIGHBORHOODS. THE STARTLING
REALITY IS WE FINANCED TRAGIC
STREET RACING STORIES IN THE
NEWS EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND ON
OUR STREETS ON OUR HIGHWAYS AND
IN OUR INTERSECTIONS. EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE CRASHES AS
A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON VICTIMS
FAMILIES IN EVERY SINGLE STREET
RACE. IS PREVENTABLE. AB THREE
PROVIDE BOND FOR SPENT AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO PUT A STOP
TO THIS DEADLY CRIME AND
PROTECT OUR YOUTH. PERFORMING
RECKLESS SPEED STANDS AND
PARTICIPATING AS YOU RACES ARE
EQUALLY DANGEROUS AND BOTH POSE
AN EQUAL RISK TO OUR ROADS
HOWEVER ONLY A CONVICTION FOR
THE LATTER CAN RESULT IN A
SUSPENDED LICENSE AB THREE.
CLOSES THAT LOOPHOLE THIS BILL
IS A BIPARTISAN MEASURE IN A
SUPPORTED BY STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND MOTHERS AGAINST
DRUNK DRIVING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER. FONG SEEING IN HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR ALL
ALL MEMBERS TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE. YEAH WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THE ICE FOUR
KNOWS THIS PASSED. MOVE TO FILE
ANYTHING SEVEN ONE TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND
IN A RELATING TO BE.
BOERNER HORVATH ARE RECOGNIZED
MADAM MEMBERS AB ONE TWENTY TWO
WOULD MAKE INTEREST SAFER FOR
PRICE. DRIVERS NUMBER. BY
ALLOWING BY. TO TREES SIGNS AS
YIELD SIGNS WHEN APPROACHING AN
INNER WITH A STOP. WHEN WELL
THIS PLACE COUNTER AND- YIELD
IS ALREADY A LOT. NO ONE'S BLUE
THROUGH THIS SIGN. IT PROVIDES
THE LEGAL. AN EXPERT. FOR THOSE
WERE TO YOU. AT A STOP SIGNS
UNDER EXIST LAW THE OF A
VEHICLE INCLUDING BY
APPROACHING IT IN OUR WITH THE
U. RIGHT OF WAY SO. MUST YIELD
TO ANY THE IN PROTEST. THAT
HAVE ENTERED THE INTERSECTION.
IF IT IS SAFE TO DO SO. EIGHT
ONE TWENTY TWO USES OF CALM
UNDER. OF A YOU SIGN ALLOW BY
APPROACH IT STOPS. TO SLOW DOWN
AND YIELD TO ANY CARS AND
PEDESTRIANS ALREADY AT THE
INTERSECTION. IF IT'S SAFE TO
DO SO THE BIKER COULD THEN
CONTINUE THROUGH THE
INTERSECTION WITHOUT MAKING A
FULL AND COMPLETE STOP.
DELAWARE ADOPTED A STOP OF YOUR
LAW FOR BICYCLES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE DELAWARE STATE
POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS RECENTLY
REPORTED A 23% REDUCTION IN
ACCIDENTS INVOLVING BICYCLISTS
AT INTERSECTIONS. DURING JUST
THE FIRST THREE MONTHS OF THE
FLOPPING INTO EFFECT. IN FACT
OF THE SEVERAL STATES HAVE
ALREADY PASSED UP WITH YOUR
BOSS NONE HAVE DISCOVERED
ANYTHING OTHER THAN
IMPROVEMENTS TO INTERSECTIONS
FIFTY. WHETHER CALIFORNIANS
RIGHT FOR RECREATION AS PART OF
A SUSTAINABLE LIFESTYLE CHOICES
OR BECAUSE IT'S THEIR ONLY
MEANS OF TRANSPORTATION. AB ONE
TWENTY TO ENSURE THE BICYCLIST
DRIVERS AND PEDESTRIANS ARE
SAFER AT INTERSECTIONS AB ONE
TRYING TO WOULD REQUIRE THE-CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH A
FIFTY REPORT AFTER FIVE YEARS.
AND ONE THOUGHT THAT AFTER SIX
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE NOW
CONGRESSMAN FROM BRIGADIER FOR
RUNNING THE SPIRIT BILL SEVERAL
YEARS AGO. IF YOU WERE HERE
WITH US ON THE FLOOR TODAY WE
BE RUNNING IT TOGETHER. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU BERNARD.
SEEING IN HERE NO FURTHER TO ON
THEM THE THIRD WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESERVE
A- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ON FARMERS THIRTY THIRD
VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEM SIXTY EIGHT AND SIXTY NINE
MOVING T FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER VALID
THERE IS AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
PROVIDERS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN. WILL TWO WILL IMPROVE
ACCESS TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROTECTION PROGRAMS FOR VICTIMS
WHO DO NOT SPEAK ENGLISH.
MEMBERS NEARLY HALF OF THE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT
HOME. MANY OF THEM LIVE IN MY
DISTRICT. UNFORTUNATELY ONE
THIRD OF THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
MEMBERS IF YOU LOOK TO YOUR
RIGHT. MEMBERS IF YOU LOOK TO
YOUR LEFT ONE OF THE THREE OF
YOU IS A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. FOR VICTIMS WHO DO
NOT SPEAK ENGLISH FLUENTLY
THEIR ABILITY TO MEANINGFULLY
ACCESS LIFE SAVING SERVICES AND
ASSISTANCE FROM STATE RESOURCES
CAN BE SEVERELY HAMPERED. TO
THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE WE
MUST WORK TO BREAK DOWN THE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS THAT ARE
PREVENTING VULNERABLE VICTIMS
FROM RECEIVING HELP. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY SEVEN DOES
JUST THAT IT IMPROVED ACCESS TO
THE STATE SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM
AND OTHER PROTECTIVE SERVICES
SO THAT ALL VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REGARDLESS OF WHAT
LANGUAGE THEY SPEAK. CAN
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED. AB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISSPELLED
ADDRESS. IT'S DAVIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT MISS WALDRON
FAST. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
TODAY I RISE AS A PROUD JOIN
AUTHOR OF AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
DUE TO THE COLD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE'VE UNFORTUNATELY
SEEN AN INCREASE IN REPORTED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES AROUND
OUR STATE THE PANDEMIC STAY AT
HOME ORDER MEANT VICTIMS
ACTUALLY BEING TRAPPED AT HOME.
AB TWO SEVEN SEVENS A SIMPLE
MEASURE TO ENSURE THAT VICTIMS
HAVE ADDITIONALLY INFORMATION
ABOUT THE TYPES OF PROGRAMS THE
STATE OFFERS TO ENSURE THE
PROTECTION AND A PATH TO
RECOVERY I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
DAVIES. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER IS
HOW IT IS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE MEMBERS FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU BURKE WILL OPEN THEIR-
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO THERE TO VOTE. WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THOSE I SEVENTY FIVE NEWS HERE
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN AND VIOLATING
SEVENTY ONE THREE SEVENTY THREE
MOVING A FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR
AC ARE SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO LIMB LOSS AWARENESS
MONTH. KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I TODAY
I ASK THAT WE DEDICATE APRIL AS
A LIMB LOSS AWARENESS MONTH
THERE ARE ABOUT TWO POINT ONE
MILLION INDIVIDUALS IN THE
UNITED STATES LIVING WITH LIMB
LOSS OR LIMB DIFFERENCE AND
OVER FIVE HUNDRED AMERICANS
LOSING THEM EVERY DAY MUCH OF
THIS IS PREVENTABLE WHICH IS
WHY AWARENESS IS SO IMPORTANT.
ACR SIXTY FIVE PROCLAIMS THE
MONTH OF APRIL TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE IN APRIL OF EACH
YEAR THEREAFTER AS A LIMB LOSS
AWARENESS MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
THE NPT COALITION WHOSE MISSION
IS TO EMPOWER PEOPLE AFFECTED
BY THEM LOS FIRST PROPOSED THE
IDEA OF AN AWARENESS MONTH IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN AND IT'S NOW
CELEBRATED ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES AND THE WORLD. THE LOSS
OF A LIMB IS NOT SIMPLY THE
LOSS- PHYSICAL LOSS BUT ALSO
IMPOSES A TOLL ON ONE'S MENTAL
HEALTH. DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY
IS COMMON IN MANY SURVIVORS OF
THEM LOS AND ASIDE FROM THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL BURDEN
THERE'S ALSO A FINANCIAL
BURDEN. THE LIFETIME HEALTH
CARE COSTS FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
LIMB LOSS CAN BE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THESE
COSTS COME IN THE FORM OF
SURGERIES MEDICATION PHYSICAL
THERAPY AND EXPENSIVE
PROSTHETICS THAT NEED TO BE
REPLACED OVER THE COURSE OF
ONE'S LIFE. JUST TO NAME A FEW.
THIS IS ALL OF COURSE BUT GOT
MUCH MORE CHALLENGING DURING
COVERT NINETEEN. THE LOCKDOWN
PERIOD HAD A SIGNIFICANT EFFECT
ON NON COVERED RELATED VASCULAR
PATIENTS HEALTH. WITH MANY
INDIVIDUALS STRUGGLING TO REACH
THEIR HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND
TO REACH THE TREATMENT THAT
THEY NEEDED. AS REPORTED IN THE
ANNALS OF VASCULAR SURGERY
RESEARCHERS FOUND MORE THAN TWO
FOLD INCREASE IN MAJOR
AMPUTATIONS AND THE DEGREE OF
TISSUE LOSS. FOR BASS YOUR
SURGERY PATIENTS AFTER TWO
AFTER COVERED NINETEEN. WITH
ALL THE FACTORS CONSIDERED IS
PROJECTED THAT THE NUMBER OF
AMPUTATIONS PER DAY WILL DOUBLE
BY TWO THOUSAND FIFTY AND LET'S
KEEP PREVENTION MEASURES ARE
PUT IN PLACE. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING APRIL AS
A LIMB LOSS AWARENESS MONTH.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION. MR KILEY DO
WANT TO OPEN THE FIRST ROLE FOR
AUTHORS. IF THE FIRST ROLE WE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. THIRTY
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS.
THERE TO VOTE THIS IS FOR CO OP
ON THE RESOLUTION. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRED VOTE THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON RESOLUTION.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TWO THE THERE ARE SO EIGHT
COOPER UNEASY R. SIX FIVE WITH
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A BOY VOTE
ON RESOLUTION. ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. I'LL SAY NO. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RED. IS ADOPTED. WE WILL
PASS THE RETAINER FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE THROUGH A MEMBERS
WE WILL NOW TO THIS DAY CA
CALENDAR ITEM ONE THROUGH ONE
OF AND ONE TWENTY THREE ONE TWO
ONE. THERE ARE WRESTLING ON
TODAY'S CONTENT CALENDAR BEFORE
YOU VOTE WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP
THE RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSE OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SOME
CURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY BY
SOME REMEMBER FONG RELATIVE TO
BE WHERE MARK ASSEMBLY CURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY RELATIVE
TO CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
17% ELEVEN OTHERS RELATIVE TO
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETEEN BY CENTER LEYVA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO EQUAL PAY
DAY. THE CLERK WHEN I OPEN THE
ROAD TO. MEMBERS TO ADD ON A
COOPER TO THESE. ALL MEMBER
VOTED GUARD ABOUT IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALLMAN
VOTED ROAD IS FOR A CO AUTHORS
ON THE RED. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELLING THERE ARE
SEVENTY THREE AUTHORS THE
RENTAL. MOVING TO VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR. BY ITEMS EIGHTY THREE
PER ONE TWO THREE DOES MEMBER
WHICH TO REMOVE AND I FROM THE
CONSENT. SEEING NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ THIS I CAN CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY BUILT THIRTY BY OF
GALLAGHER OTHER AND ACT TO BE.
WELL OVER THE WRONG. ALL MY
VOTE WHO DESIRED OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OF THE- YEAH
DEGREE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED A.
WHERE WELL THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES I SEVENTY NEWS ZERO
THEY CAN CALENDARS ADOPTED THE
CLERK WILL READ THEIR MEANING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY SIX
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE OH FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
NINE ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIFTY NINE WITH URGENCY. FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS THEY'RE ON
THERE TO THE I. SEVENTY FOUR
NEWS HERE ON THE MATTER
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHTY.
SEVENTY NEAR ZERO ASSEMBLY
BEFORE TWENTY NINE FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR AND IS THERE ARE SOME OF
THE FOR THIRTY ONE SEVENTY NO
ZERO SUM GO FORTH FIVE SEVEN
FOUR NOW IS THERE ARE SOME FOR
FORTY FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NEWS
THERE ARE SOME LEGAL FINAL FOR.
SEVEN FOREIGNERS THERE ARE SOME
BILL FIVE THIRTY TWO HI SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO BILL FORTY.
SEVENTY NEWS ARE SOME PEOPLE
FIVE SO NINE SEVENTY FOUR NEW
ZERO SOME PEOPLE FOR NINETY.
SEVENTY FOUR AND IS THERE ARE
SOME LEGAL SIXTEEN SEVEN I FOUR
AND ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
THIRTY EIGHT. SEVENTY FOUR ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINE. FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR AND IS ASSEMBLY
BILL SO FOUR HI SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO SUM YOU DON'T. I SEVEN
FOUR KNOWS ARE SOME EITHER ONE
SEVEN FOUR EWS THERE ARE SOME
EACH SIX SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS SUM
FOR OH FIVE. SEVENTY FOUR AND
ZERO OF THE SOME OF THE FORTY
SEVENTY SO. SEVENTY FOUR NINE
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOLUTIONS FIVE SEVENTY
NO ZERO SUM IT RESOLUTION SIXTY
SIX SEVEN CORNERS SOME BILL
FIFTY SIXTY FOR. SEVENTY FOUR
AND A THERE A SYMBOL FOR FORTY
I FOUR NINE ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTY FOUR SEVENTY AND IS THERE
ARE SOME OF FIVE TO SEVEN I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL. SIX ONE SEVENTY KNOWS THE
ASSUMING RESOLUTION NINE.
SEVENTY FOUR AND IS ARE SOME
CURRENT RESOLUTION TO SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND IS THERE SUM
CONSUMERS FOR ONE SEVENTY FOUR
KNOWS. CYNICAL RESOLUTION
SEVENTY SEVENTY FOUR IS THERE
CURRENTLY NINETEEN. SEVENTY
FOUR ZERO SENATE CONCURRENCE
TOWARD FIVE SEVENTY FOUR NEWS.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS QUORUM CALL
IS NOW LIFTED WE ARE MOVING TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY I ASK
THAT YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS. OFF
THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS. MS CLARK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I REQUIRE A
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF CHRIS MOON KI NAM
RESIDENT OF THE SIXTY FIFTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN THE CITY
OF FULLERTON IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO MISTER NAM IMMIGRATED TO
THE UNITED STATES WITH ONLY
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN HIS
POCKET HE CAME TO AMERICA WITH
HONESTY AND UP YOUR PASSION TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. HE WORKED AT
VARIOUS JOBS TO MAKE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY HIS BILLS SOON
AFTER THAT HE STUDIED REAL
ESTATE AND BECAME A REAL ESTATE
AGENT AFTER WORKING IN THIS
FIELD FOR SEVERAL YEARS HE
BEGAN NEW STAR REALITY IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WHICH IS
NOW THE LARGEST KOREAN AMERICAN
REAL ESTATE GROUP IN THE UNITED
STATES. HIS JOURNEY LED HIM TO
BECOMING THE HEAD OF THE
LARGEST ASIAN HELD REAL ESTATE
AGENCY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WITH OVER THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL SALES AND OVER. TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AGENTS.
MR NAM'S PHILO'S WAS TO HELP
MANY KOREAN IMMIGRANTS FIND
HOPE SUCCESS AND STABILITY IN
THE UNITED STATES HE WORKS TO
ACHIEVE THIS THROUGH HIS REAL
ESTATE BRANCHES. MISTER NAM
STARTED HIS REAL ESTATE IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND NOW THERE ARE
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND KOREAN AMERICANS THAT
THE- REAL ESTATE FIRM HAS HELP
SERVE. HE HAS ALSO BEEN IN STE
EXTREMELY VISIONARY AND HOW TO
ADVERTISE AND REACH THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH VARIOUS FORMS
OF MEDIA INCLUDING NEWSPAPER
TELEVISION RADIO AND EVEN
SPONSORSHIPS HE PUT A PERSONAL
STAMP ON THE INS INDUSTRY
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE YEARS HE'S RECEIVED
NUMEROUS AWARDS HE HAS ALSO
BEEN A FRIEND TO STUDENTS
MAKING SURE THAT HE PROVIDED
SCHOLARSHIPS TO MANY MANY
STUDENTS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. IN
ADDITION TO THIS HE SERVED IN
LEADERSHIP ROLES MANY LOCAL AND
NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING PRESIDENT OF THE
KOREAN AMERICAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE OF THE UNITED STATES
PRESIDENT OF THE KOREAN
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF LOS
ANGELES PRESIDENT OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY KOREAN MARINE CORPS
ASSOCIATION AND PRESIDENT OF
THE AMERICAN REALTOR
ASSOCIATION YOU CAN SEE THAT HE
WAS A VERY VERY BUSY GENTLEMEN.
HE LIVED AS A MENTOR AND A THE
LEGENDARY SUCCESS ICON FOR THE
CURRY IN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
WILL BE REMEMBERED FONDLY AS A
PASSIONATE AND GIVING MEMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU MISS
CLARK SILVA. MISTER AND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
ASK THAT WE TURNED IN MEMORY OF
FORMER GARDEN GROVE MAYOR BILL
DALTON WILLIAM BILL DALTON WAS
BORN IN SAN FRANCISCO ON
DECEMBER THIRD NINETEEN FORTY
TWO TO HARD WORKING BLUE COLLAR
FAMILY IT WAS THE YOUNGEST. OF
FIVE CHILDREN. MR DALTON'S LONG
AND DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC CAREER
BEGAN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
WHEN HE PURSUE HIS DREAM AND
BECAME A POLICE OFFICER. FOR
THE GARDEN GROVE POLICE
DEPARTMENT. SERVING FOR TWENTY
SIX YEARS WITH THE GARDEN WILL
PLEASE. HE ROSE TO THE RANK OF
LIEUTENANT AND WAS HONORED WITH
THE MEDAL OF VALOR THE HIGHEST
AWARD A POLICE OFFICER CAN
RECEIVE FOR STOPPING AN ARMED
ROBBERY. AT THE END OF HIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAREER. MAYOR
DALTON SERVE ON THE CARGO CITY
COUNCIL FROM. NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND FOUR HE
WAS ELECTED AS MAYOR IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR IT WAS REELECTED
IN 200-062-0008 AND TWO
THOUSAND TEN. I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE AND THE HONOR OF
SERVING WOULD MAYOR DALTON. IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR WHEN HE
BECAME OUR MAYOR. HE IS NOT
JUST A FRIEND. HE'S A MENTOR
AND SOMEONE I KNOW WHO HAS MY
BACK HAS ALWAYS BEEN
SUPPORTIVE. OF WHAT I DO. WE
CAMPAIGN TOGETHER WALK
PRECINCTS TOGETHER WE LAUGH
TOGETHER WE CRY TOGETHER. AND
WE ALSO ARGUE AGAINST EACH
OTHER AS WELL. BUT I CAN'T ASK
FOR ANYTHING MORE. THAT'S WHO
MAYOR DALTON IS. MY HOMETOWN OF
GARDEN GROVE WOULD NOT BE THE
CITY IT IS TODAY WITHOUT THE
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION OF
BILL. HE'S HELP TO BEAUTIFY OUR
CITY. IT MADE IT A VERY
WELCOMING COMMUNITY FOR ALL
RESIDENTS AND VISITORS. AS
MENTIONED I AM PROUD TO NOT
ONLY CALL HIM MY FRIEND. MY
MAYOR HE WILL FOREVER BE
REMEMBERED BY OUR CITY FOR HIS
COURAGE. AND LEADERSHIP A TRULY
REMARKABLE INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS
FOR RIGHT AND HONEST DEMEANOR
AND FIND PERSONAL EXAMPLE WHERE
AN INSPIRATION TO THOSE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE HE HAS TOUCHED. MAYOR
BILL DALTON WILL BE REMEMBERED
AS A DEVOTED FAMILY MAN AND A
DEVOTED AND DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANT. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF FIFTY NINE YEARS SANDI.
HIS CHILDREN PATRICIA WILLIAM
JUNIOR. PANELA PAULA ROBERT AND
BRIAN WHO CURRENTLY SERVES. ON
THE IN THE GARDEN GROVE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN FOURTEEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVENTEEN
GREAT GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
AGAIN I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF FORMER MAYOR BILL
DALTON THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MATTHEW RYAN MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAME THREE DEATHS WE
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS TODAY'S
COMMITTEE SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS. HIGHER EDUCATION WILL
BE AT TEN THIRTY HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT WILL MEET AT TEN
THIRTY IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION WILL MEET AT TEN
THIRTY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO.
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONAL ME TO
PM HERE IN THE CHAMBER AND
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE WILL
MEET AT TWO THIRTY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO. THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
APRIL TWENTY THIRD NO FOURTH
SESSION IN A CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY APRIL TWENTY SIXTH FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM ALL OTHER
ITEMS THROUGH THE REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAINED ALL
MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MR BONTA MOOSE AND MISTER JOHN
FOR A SECOND BUT THIS HOUSING
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY APRIL
TWENTY SIXTH AT. ONE PM.
YEAH
WHY NOT.